тут на кордоні слова шину і народ витя
мій будні українську на ринкову
закладеності раниш і педалі газу править
пороку чого впав у вас русі йду за хімію
європи ppsu синім трубопроводам газу
ужгород не біг ці слова чини в україну
обсяги реверсних поставок нехай і
зростають посмішки в українських
засовуєш я закачав і по надфіль
мільярда кубометрі слабкість до багажу а
запишу половину серпня імпорту зробив крок у
80 з'явиться таких ідеально булатного
общагу заправить військовий ужгород за
проти фу vrs не - горяку
по і гніздо китай підлогу імпорту і c pіз
по середньому
слова слова чини в тебе чоловік транзитному
пункті ви вже начебто розміщення чітери
магістральні трубопроводи століттями
російський газпром пусто чаю підлоги вода
захи ної Європи до його відобразивши архів
прибрати і слабкий дозвольте розвідним з
їх слід було б вузли весь знач нас
бюджет та опціях у рот них потоки в
україну all з лаваша набачилася а
що посилають на воду з правом ти мені
mind if i do леру б ставку на реверсі
слова чини пошуки та укладені
за майже сім місяців поточних уроку
україна імпортувала за галон більше
11 мільярдів кубометрів газу. 2 тритон
з них сподіваєшся з євросоюзу за русь її
допитував ікони посту чани газу україна
була застосована відходу вал відриті на вигляд
досить а психу імпорту і ряд українців
раз по ряду все до 1 жовта на капу що
ти Україні 17 мільярдів кубометрів газу
і все йому ту і викручують, наприклад
дашівських а за школи сеулі всякі
області у тисяча дев'ятсот вісімдесят
шостому уроці ви дуб цю крадіжку тут був
зуб і але суди
вже надходити хіба слова чана всі ті
роки російські як би ти словацький
принципі всі завдання, де ти на вірність
ресурсів але заявлено в ряду загального
підземних собачих українців на найвищій
тряс палубну мільярди кубометрі ходжу
10 якуз erp не рамірез був успішно ні
слова шину в україну щоб вона
споживає 30 мільйонів кубу моя 3 таким
чином краще за рахунок чого реверсу на
капучино громади обсі я ходжу до початку
холоді
не вдастся
і